Honduras ha entrado en un estado de
excepción en el marco de una estrategia
nacional para combatir a las maras y
pandillas y a las organizaciones
relacionadas con el crimen organizado y
el narcotráfico unos veinte mil policías
han sido desplazados en las últimas
horas A diferentes barrios y colonias
considerados de alta incidencia de
criminalidad en las ciudades de
Tegucigalpa y San Pedro Sula esta medida
ha sido tomada por la presidenta
Xiomara Castro ante El clamor popular y
ante los elevados índices de
criminalidad en el país también a raíz
de denuncias interpuestas por miembros
del transporte público quienes han
manifestado que unos 60 de sus miembros
han sido asesinados en lo que va del año
por negarse a pagar extorsión a estos
grupos criminales quienes exigen el pago
de esta extorsión a cambio según ellos
de dejarles trabajar libremente esta
medida ha causado cierta confusión en la
población sin embargo la Policía
Nacional ha explicado que los ciudadanos
pueden circular libremente en estas
zonas donde se ha implementado la
medidas sin embargo Ellos están
facultados para requerirlos pedirles
identificación en el momento que lo
estimen conveniente